that's a new lineup
i love the look
oh my god love you bro captain carter
well something larger than life on
august
guns are larger than life theonix
manga that's weird and ask yourself the
question
what the evidence is
[Laughter]
welcome back to new rock stars marvel
studios animated series what if
is one week away with nine episodes each
presenting a hypothetical scenario based
on the long-running marvel comics series
here presented by the watcher voiced by
jeffrey wright
who is the creepo in the sky who knows
what video you just clicked away from
what the if
what if i love with the f so much we're
going with like the f
i feel good about what the if that's
gonna be fun
how do you guys feel about it let us
know you're gonna let us know anyway if
you don't like it we don't care
we're gonna stick with what the if it's
perfect this is inside marvel it's our
weekly marvel discussion that for the
next two months will be our official
what if after show i'm eric voss i'm
here with mt
what if i got to talk about what if with
my favorite guy eric voss
what's going on eric i'm so excited for
this series um
everything we've seen from it so far
just looks crazy
um i know not everyone's going to
immediately
jump on board with uh with an animated
version but this is still marvel studios
and it still seems to be pretty canon at
least for the people making this show
and it remains to be seen how much will
be brought into live action
uh but i think it's still going to be
very much essential
must-see tv or must-see stream mean
uh every week that's how we're looking
at it oh yeah for sure if you like the
mcu do not skip what if because this is
like they got the
same actors from the fcu reprising their
roles and like these are basically new
mcu stories
told in a different medium so i'm
excited it's going to be good and we're
going to go over
how canon exactly all of this will be
we're going to give you a series preview
and breakdown everything you need to
know
going into what if and i mentioned nine
episodes at the start of this episode
that's because the series order of ten
episodes was actually recently revised
to nine
the tenth episode was pushed to uh
season two that's right we're getting
the second season of this
which is already and executive producer
brad winterbomb
confirmed what the first three episodes
will be we knew the pilot was going to
be what if peggy carter took the super
soldier serum instead of steve rogers
second episode's gonna be what if
t'challa became star-lord instead of
peter quill
and in this episode other guardians
cameos are expected including yondu the
collector ego howard the duck and more
and it was actually reported that the
late chadwick boseman voices t'challa
not just this episode but four
episodes this season we're gonna get
four extra episodes of chadwick boseman
i don't think i'm emotionally ready dog
i don't know
i don't know it's gonna be great uh and
then episode three
is an episode that is going to show
loki's arrival to earth
but loki has come to earth before so why
is this a big deal well this appears to
be set during fury's big week
during the events of iron man 2 thor and
hulk based on trailer footage
that shows some of these specific events
including tony stark and the donut
and the moment of hulk where hawkeye
aims and arrow at him but based on other
trailer shots i point out in our first
trailer breakdown some of those arrows
do fly so are we going to see
a what if hawkeye killed thor episode
and that could be why loki appears early
that would be kind of wild now
uh empty what are some other episodes
that we've been able to surmise from
trailer footage we'll be in this season
well we all we also got what if
zombies overran the mcu because we see
uh you know bucky fighting that cat
zombie
and we also see from the original
trailer janet van dyne in the quantum
realm
a zombified jenna van dyne um so it's
it could be possible that she could have
brought that from the quantum realm but
who knows and we also see
spider-man um as well and that
spider-man could be in the zombies
episode it could be in a different
episode that we'll get to
we also saw a trailer shot of what if
killmonger saved tony stark in
afghanistan
that's going to be fascinating to see um
then we also got what if odin didn't
adopt loki and
loki became party thor this is all
according to tom middleton in an
interview
so that's gonna be really interesting
guys loki i don't know what that means
i have no idea what that quote means but
i'm excited to see it
oh god now trailer footage has also
shown us a couple different
avengers lineups we saw one in the
teaser at the beginning of our reaction
here that had black panther with the
other avengers but we also saw one of
trailers where it's gamora carrying
thanos's sword
and then black panther and star-lord and
thor that could be the party thor
episode we're not exactly sure yet
then we also see natasha romanoff in a
post-apocalyptic setting
uh which could be the zombie episode but
it could be another like maybe an age of
ultron
type episode but i don't really know yet
but she also has red guardian shield
which is very
interesting to me um that's gonna be
real fun uh there's gonna be some dr
strange centric episode where we know
there's gonna be like a doctor strange
supreme
and we know spider-man's gonna be in a
doctor strange cloak of levitation
so are we gonna see alternate people
playing uh the sorcerer's supreme in
different realities
and we're gonna have one episode of what
if that bridges a lot of different
realities within it i would love to see
professor hulk as a source for supreme
please give it to me like a maestro
like for sure oh my god so good um but
we also have an episode in which scott
lang's head is in like a jar
like a glass jar futurama style so
i'm really interested to see how that
even happened because good god what did
you do scott
what was so different yeah maybe that's
the zombie one right like he
had to preserve like there's some kind
of weird reanimation
virus but they kept him from turning to
a zombie i don't know what i'm saying oh
my
gosh no like no that that probably is
actually what happened because his body
got infected so they just took his head
off
that that's 100 percent plausible i like
that right
uh and then we have um we have we've
seen some shots of scarlet witch
like fully par powered up at scarlet
witch where okoye throws a spear at her
and then
uh vision pulling out the mind stone
from his own head
these could be the same episode that
could be different episodes but the
question is
which of these episodes could turn out
to be actual canon in the live-action
mcu
any of them all of them well
uh before we continue with that if you
are still hoping to grab black widow's
latest obsession the red deep shirt this
week is your last chance to get it
before it goes in the vault and it's
gone forever
like natasha herself from the mcu it's
being taken to the red room by force
so you guys hurry up but uh big news
this weekend alongside the big
theatrical release of james gunn's
suicide squad we are launching our new
latest obsession number six bad company
i don't know if i'm allowed to sing that
a little bit demonetized
i'm so excited for this shirt though
just like the crazy dangerous ensemble
the characters from this summer's
biggest adventure these shirts are here
for a good time but not for a long time
so check out our new latest obsession on
friday august 6th it's the same day the
suicide squad
hits the theaters and you can check out
that and all of our great merch options
at new rockstarsmerch.com
okay so our first question of the day
eric is what if
any of the what-if episodes have actual
canonical implications
on upcoming mcu's titles like doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
hmm well marvel studios certainly wants
us to think that's going to be the case
for sure absolutely watch the show
everything is going to be essential and
important and we'll be on the test
at the end of the it's all required
reading
yeah i i think so i like to think so
yeah uh and it's reading for us because
we put on the subtitles and just read
the subtitles and then i do a second
watch where i look at all the imagery
and then merge
my two brains i put the brain and the
broad after 18 months in the gamma lab
hey bro i'm an anime nerd so subtitles
is what i do so
hey all day every day so just to look at
what the people working on the show have
said head writer ac bradley declared
that the events of what if are canon
it's part of the mcu multiverse the
multiverse is here it's real
and it's absolutely fantastic people
yeah used to weinfeld
yes it's real and it's fantastic
executive producer brad winterbomb said
quote it's no coincidence that the show
picks up right after loki
the multiverse has erupted in every
possible direction
and that what if gives marvel quote a
chance to explore that
i think that without going into great
detail i can tell you that what if
as a project as a story that exists in
the mcu
is as important as any other and is
woven into that tapestry
and tom hiddleston who as we said voices
in at least one episode
confirmed quote it sets up a whole bunch
of stuff in the mcu
which i know nothing about he's lying he
knows everything
yeah he knows he knows he knows now mt
on one hand it's easy to follow the loki
finale and say oh the mcu is a
multiverse of possibilities now
have anything and everything on the show
is going to be canon hypothetically and
technically they'd be right that is true
but i think when it comes to our
purposes canonicity only really matters
if any of these animated elements return
in live action
in a future mcu movie or tv series
rather than what if
it just if it just stays animated
forever it's gonna have a different
weight i think in most viewers minds
it'll always be important to us
sure but what we're really excited is to
see these characters show up in a like
with the actors playing them in live
action
now of the episodes we have seen footage
of here are some episodes i think we
should watch closely in terms of the
dialogue the visuals the plot mechanics
the rules of the world that are being
established in that alternate reality
for some possible clues about an
upcoming title and how it might play out
and i think the
first thing i talked about is the doctor
strange episode oh yeah we got it
and i don't know i i kind of suspect
based on looking at
trailer footage that the scenario might
be what if christine palmer died in the
car crash and that strange was given a
chance to rescue her from the afterlife
um just because it seems like that
simple idea of alternate sorcerer
supreme
would tell us a lot about marvel's plans
or what they don't plan on doing
for doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and spider-man no way home
what do you think mt i think that that's
a really uh
on the money uh assessment because like
we do see christine palmer or
a woman in some type of dark realm with
doctor strange as he's shooting out
this dark energy or stark fire energy
out of his hands
so uh having it it would make sense
given the you know the origin story of
doctor strange where he takes over
the royal social supreme from the
ancient one who
uses dark like magic to sustain her but
what makes our doctor strange
super special is that like he doesn't
fall into that temptation he's just like
all right we're gonna defeat dormammu
and like i don't need to live forever
like
the ancient one did but like this doctor
strange could have potentially
got messed up in some dark magic he was
like hey this is some really great stuff
if she could do it why not i could i'm
dr strange i'm super smart i can handle
it
and uh we're probably gonna figure out
that he can't handle it and we're gonna
see some
really uh dark doctor strange stuff yeah
and i
i think the um a good rule of thumb is
any one episode of what if that brings
in multiple variants of the same
character
in a universe together is something that
will give us a clue to how it could
appear in live action because if they're
willing to bridge universes within the
animated side of the world
it'll mean that they're willing to
bridge universes in live action the way
that we saw with loki
and if that happens in the doctor
strange episode i will not be surprised
if we see some alternate sorcerers
supreme
in multiverse of madness and if we see
alternate peter parker specifically with
a sorcerer's supreme peter parker or
parker now we don't know if that's the
case he might just be wearing the cloak
of levitation in that shot
but if it is an alternate peter that
might be an indicator of the way no way
home might go it shows that like
it's telling fancy you see the idea of
seeing variants of peter parker
right i wonder because like we we hear
that uh this
peter parker is not being voiced by tom
holland so i wonder if
you know this is a completely different
peter parker but this is a peter parker
that might end up dying
because like it's a different version so
like maybe we might see this peter
parker die in an episode of what if
because
there's no stakes like we don't know
this man so it's just maybe it's just
like setting up those multiversal stakes
like
hey anyone can die who knows how much
would you lose your mind mt
if the person who was voicing spider-man
was andrew garfield
bro i would myself i would
literally just be
i would freak out i'd be like yo they're
doing it like we got
like some type of confirmation
spider-verse finally confirmed
yo like i would just be like elated bro
like you don't even tease i wish you
didn't even bring that up because now
i'm sorry
another episode i think we should talk
about is the scarlet witch and vision
episode
this is footage that we've seen the
least of in the
trailer footage that exists so far i
wonder
if this might be the episode that was
pushed do you think it's possible that
the pushed episode
did show up in trailer footage would
they have included any of that footage
because according to the show runner it
made it sound like they just ran out of
time
uh and that they wanted to reconfigure
it but that doesn't make a lot of sense
to me because this animated stuff could
have been worked on from home
it can still be worked on from home and
they have two months until the season
finale
so like why would they now punt on it i
wonder if there's like plot
reasons why like stuff is being reworked
around
scarlet witch's future in the mcu and
that's why they
had to rework it i really hope that it's
just like uh we had one idea for scarlet
scarlet witch and vision episode but
like we're just gonna scrap that and
just do like a what if with uh
like one division like a different take
on one division because everyone wants
another season of one division
so i feel like the best way that they
could do that is just like here's an
episode
of what if that has a different take on
one division like what if
the one division kept going forever like
what if the the bubble expanded what if
the world became one division
i think that'd be really fun so i i hope
that it's just like a
you know what we have a different vision
for what we are doing
um another episode to keep our eye on is
that if it is the zombie episode the
shot of janet
van dyne in the quantum realm the fact
that we're going back to the quantum
realm is very interesting
we need to keep our eyes peeled when we
go to the quantum realm because
are they gonna put that city in the
background again are we going to get
some kang
chronopolis hints again i feel like it'd
be a good opportunity just to throw it
in there to remind us that
you know there's something there oh yeah
for sure and like there's another thing
that people don't really think about is
that like we know that there's a city in
the background but like
a lot of the marvel people that consumed
mcu content
have no idea that the city is there so i
think it'd be a really great opportunity
before
quantum mania to point people in that
direction like hey there's a city here
like years
we're going to tease you what's going on
and we're gonna go into it in quantum
mania well do you think it could be
something to where
kang in that reality uh decided to
infect that reality with the zombie
outbreak and gave janet van dyne
this virus so that when she gets sucked
back out of the quantum realm
it causes this mass zombie outbreak to
happen and that's how kang
just decided to rid himself of that
reality you know
bro that would be a a genius plan like
get rid of
everybody it's very messy
fun fun there's different keg variants
they work in different ways whatever
floats your tank vote you know what i'm
saying
[Laughter]
now uh we should acknowledge there was
apparently one episode of uh
this that the guardians of the galaxy
episode that they had to scrap
because it was too similar to what james
gunn has planned in his script for
guardians volume three
which is fascinating right like it makes
you wonder what specific
bonkers is james gunn planning that
was supposed to be a what if
episode right it's so insane it was
gonna be what if like that makes me even
more excited for volume three
right i saw that this morning i was like
what could it be like is it what if like
rocket never meant groot like it could
be anything like scenarios there
another episode to keep our eye on is
the pilot of course captain peggy carter
um and in trailer footage she's fighting
some um
tentacled monster from another dimension
uh mt and i were talking before the
episode
thinking it's the uh the many angled
ones perhaps
um but what's on the other side of that
portal what does it lead to
and another an update we want to give
you uh winterbomb actually confirmed
that captain carter will be a focal
character in this series it's going to
return in season
two he said quote we realized as we
started developing the second season
that captain carter was going to be the
character we would revisit in every
season
and continue that adventure obviously
we're telling the story on a giant
multiversal canvas
so you never really know who's going to
pop up where and when
it's very much an anthology but there's
always an opportunity for fun
connections to be made
wow okay so we're putting captain carter
on like
the biggest like mcu irl like
transition watch like we're probably
going to see her this um what if
character transition into the
live action mcu the most out of anyone
because of this emphasis on her
importance
within the multiple seasons of whatever
and i'm thinking like
captain britain core right like exactly
exactly if she's going to be someone who
already goes through dimensions that
she's fighting this thing and that's the
way
they tell her version of the story and
it's a multiversal story
that she's going to show up in
connections across episodes
like that's your opportunity to
introduce the core
exactly that's probably what they're
doing like that's the captive written
core right there
like oh man um but we want to remind you
of what
watchers are so we're being introduced
to uwatu the watcher
it's a very big deal watchers are cosmic
entities in marvel comics they observe
and record events of the multiverse but
they don't interfere
uatu was the watcher assigned to our
universe and once in the past he worn
the fantastic four of galactus's arrival
but about
vowed never to do this again uh watchers
appeared actually already in the mcu
back in guardians volume two they were
stuck listening to stan lee's stories
those are watchers
uh james gunn actually included them as
a nod to the popular fan theory
that stan lee was going to be the ensues
whoa to the watcher
uh but stan lee is far more powerful
than that you could argue stan lee
is the one above all right like that
would be the jack kirby analog there
wasn't
uh believe that jack kirby was the one
above all in a fantastic four comic
maybe i'm yeah it's like that was once
they do that like multiple times
throughout like the decades of like
making them
these all-powerful people i love that
they do that so yeah stanley is the most
powerful being
i think at the very least um jeffrey
wright showing up
as a watcher in the live-action mcu
might be the likeliest
thing from this show to show up because
he's already just kind of this
disembodied voice he's the way he's
designed on the show is actually closer
to eternity i would say like he's kind
of an outline a silhouette in the stars
that's what eternity looks like
uh and he looks amazing like he looks
really cool yeah
and he's also red i believe he's like
more red-ish than
than watchers which tend to be well in
the mcu they were like flesh-colored
but often they'll be blue or something
like that so i think
it's probably most likely that we see or
at least hear the voice of jeffrey
wright show up
in some future cosmic mcu story maybe
like multiverse madness like imagine
steven strange
communing with uwatu the watcher as what
you explains to him
the exact nature of this crisis oh yeah
for sure like we're definitely
uh going to see a jeffrey wright whoa
too in the mcu at least i feel like it's
not confirmed or anything but like
god like it would just be weird to hey
just to get jeffrey right for
an animated show like that just seems
like a weird they could just had anybody
voice him if they're just gonna be
animated
but uh yeah i think i think that like i
said before
because the watchers are cgi characters
they could
jeffrey wright could just be put in
whenever so like we could definitely see
uh jeffrey wright in multiverse of
madness but we could also see him in the
fantastic four because like you said
our the first time that we were
introduced to the watcher is in a
fantastic four comic
and if anyone knows where the fantastic
four even went to or why
like why we don't no one even knows a
fantastic four in the mcu
it's uh he's probably gonna be the one
that tells us what happened to the
fantastic four we have a couple more
questions we want to get to
about what if uh but if you're at all
interested in marvel content of course
you know who stan lee is and the huge
impact he had on marvel
comics the entertainment industry as a
whole what fewer fans know
is that in the early 2000s stan lee was
in
financial trouble and on the verge of
suing marvel
the all-new season of the business
movers podcast explores how
stan lee changed the comic book industry
and saved his own career in the process
on each season of business movers you'll
hear how titans of industry
rose from the bottom rung of the
corporate ladder and what obstacles they
overcame on their climb to the top
i'm excited for this podcast and for
more people to know about the part of
stanley's life between when he was
dreaming up the fantastic four and
spider-man and when he was popping up in
cameos in mcu movies
on business movers you'll find out
exactly how a kid from the bronx born at
the height of the great depression
went on to become a comic book industry
superhero
listen to the latest episode of business
movers stan lee on amazon music apple
podcasts and you can listen ad free by
joining wondering plus
in the wondery app wondering feel the
story
also if you dread looking at your credit
card statement every month upstart can
help lift that weight off your shoulders
upstart is a fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get a simple fixed monthly
payment
unlike other lenders upstart looks at
more than just your credit score like
your income your employment history
this means they can offer smarter rates
with trusted partners with a five minute
online rate check you can see your rate
up front for loans between one thousand
and fifty thousand dollars
you receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
marvel that's upstart.com marvel don't
forget to use our url to let them know
that we sent you
load amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
marvel empty we're just talking about
this before the break what if
marvel uses this series to soft
introduce the fantastic four
or the x-men yeah that would be bonkers
i think that'd be a really
bold move to use like a really
experimental show like this
because they haven't made an animated
show before to introduce the fantastic
four of the x-men that would be wild
but i think that they wouldn't but at
the very least i think that they could
use what if
to enter to reintroduce past fox
universes like the x-men universe or the
fantastic four universe because they
could easily tell what if stories
in those universes as well um and they
could get the the past actors like
jessica alba
um uh ian griffith i can't say his name
but all their
read chris evans chris evans that's
easier
um all of them um and like the the fox
x-men and like just to make
new stories and hugh jackman because we
did see um on instagram
that hugh jackman they just he was
teasing working with kevin feige to some
degree
so we were sort of we all saw that all
of us are looking at
uh
educational purposes academic reasons
purely
purely um it's word politics it's world
politics it's uh
yes yeah i think um i mean i i think
you're right it would be
pretty bold to use this animated series
to introduce
x-men but in another way of looking at
it it's kind of an
easier way for feige to softball bring
in some elements that he's not
necessarily ready to bring into the
live-action mcu
just to kind of test the waters you know
um
like for example we know a marvel
zombies episode is happening and
like that that to me i i thought we'd be
years away if they ever did a marvel
zombies movie or a marvel zombies
anything you know that has the marvel
studios title card in front of it so the
fact that they're willing to go
there for what if makes me think they
might be willing to go to some other
places
and and bring in the fantastic four and
if you just say this is an alternate
fantastic four or
alternate lower level mutants or things
like that the way they brought in
apparently ursa major into black widow
right
i wish they did that was more obvious
it's like oh yeah
by the way that guy is using some agent
don't even wear that right
yeah i it tells me that they're just a
little less precious about the exact
timing of this uh introduction that
we're gonna start seeing in little
pieces here and there uh so and i think
that might be the smarter way to go then
then we're less dependent on whatever
this uh press release to the hollywood
reporter will be of so-and-so has been
cast as wolverine so it's always been
cast as storm or cyclops or professor x
or magneto
uh because then everyone's gonna jump on
and be like i hate that casting
but if you just start to like soft
introduce the idea of like hey
it's just mutants baby it's got a little
mutant here a little
ex gene popping up in this little baby
over here don't even worry about it
anybody could be a mutant it's okay
then we're just like give us mutants
right you
we don't like who's who i feel like what
if has
sort of historically been a testing
grounds even in the context because like
you know we all know that jane foster
became thor
somewhat relatively recently like around
like the 2016-ish
area yeah but like jason aaron yeah in
the jason aaron run
but in a what if comic jane foster was
initially introduced like wave like
decades before
in what if number 10 as as a thor so
like it's those concepts that like
you know marvel plays around with that
that they could maybe go back into it
and then mess around in the future in a
more substantial way
so yeah uh smart hulk was a what if
concept right the end game writer said
that they looked at old what-if issues
to figure out what they wanted to do
with the characters
five years later and in-game exactly i
had no idea that's
amazing like i love what if as a concept
because people can just
play around without having to affect the
the main mcu like
it's it's so frustrating at times when
like a universe gets so big that like oh
man we can't really do anything
that crazy to it like we're not we know
that the marvel earth is not going to
explode in the marvel comics like it's
never going to fully
die because like it's the marvel earth
this is where our stories go but in
another universe
what if the earth exploded you know what
i'm saying so like you can do so many
different things
and then play around with it see how
people respond to it and then maybe
adapt um
a more substantial story into the
mainline marvel comics or the mcu
so i love what if as a as a concept
testing show
now uh another what if we should talk
about what if the zombie outbreak was
actually a curse from the dark hold
we talked about another uh possible
zombie
source but like we might learn in the
show
about other dark supernatural elements
that wanda could unleash from that book
this way i do like that i
it's it's very possible because the dark
holes just got introduced
and it's probably going to be a major
focal point in multiverse of madness
and it's a book of the damned
and i can't think of anything more
damned than zombies i
i don't know if you can i just anytime i
see things that are
uh more associated with supernatural
horror fiction like vampire zombies
witchcraft werewolves i always think
darkhold you know even though i know
zombies is more of a science fiction
concept
right it's a biological um
based sort of thing uh at least in the
way zombie movies have existed in the
modern era originally
zombie movies were based on the idea of
like mind control
you know the original george romero ones
in the 60s and 70s
it was more about like conformity in in
like
mass media control of a society and then
with like 28 days later in the 90s
you start to see more like oh no it was
a fear of like um
biological illnesses like uh ebola and
other
you know viruses things like that and
now that's how zombie movies have that
kind of sci-fi grounding to them but we
see the mcu
is likes to marry science and magic so
like it'd probably be a mix of like
that quantum realm ship and then
probably dark hold it's probably
gonna be both i don't know
yeah a couple more questions but first
our friends at blue chew have a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable form and at a fraction
of the cost
bluetooth is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips
it ships right to your door in a
discrete package you sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you receive your
prescription within days
their licensed medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient
and strength
and blue chew is chewable just like it
says in the name which is great news for
folks that don't like swallowing pills
so if you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluetooth.com for
more details and important safety
information and we've got a special deal
for our audience try blue chew
for free when you use our promo code
inside marvel at checkout
just pay the five dollars in shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code inside
marvel to receive your first month for
free
and we thank bluetooth for sponsoring
this show also big thanks to keeps for
sponsoring us
uh more than 50 million men in the u.s
suffer from male pattern baldness
and there are only two fda approved
medications that prevent hair loss well
good news
keeps offers both of them keeps as a
simple stress-free way to keep your hair
i personally hate going to doctors
appointments of all kinds like it's
never at a convenient time and then you
have to park you sit in the waiting room
it's a it's obviously important it's
just not very fun it's about as fun i
imagine as losing your hair
is well keeps offers convenient virtual
doctor consultations and medications
delivered straight to your door every
three months you don't have to leave
your home or go to the doctor's office
or the pharmacy
treatments start at just ten dollars per
month and keeps offers generic versions
to keep the costs low
their proven results arrive on your
doorstep and discreet packaging
keeps says more five-star reviews than
any of its competitors so with hair loss
prevention is key
treatments take four to six months to
see results so you gotta act fast
if you're ready to take action prevent
hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash marvel to receive your
first month of treatment for free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash marvel
to get your first month for free
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash marvel
all right mt i gotta ask you this this
is a selfish question for me
what if the wanda envision episode
is a one division redo with
methysto oh
i think that's exactly what's going down
no i think you don't have to you don't
have to yes and that mt if you think
you're going to do that you could say no
no no i think that it would be
really fun for them to go into that
because
one division heavily implied a mephisto
presence even though they didn't go that
direction so
i in because i think that they know
everyone was expecting a mephisto
um they could easily just be like hey
what if it was mephisto
like let's see what what would go on
with that and like and sort of explain
like the differences between
someone like agatha and someone like
mephisto because we think agatha's
ruthless
i don't know well but this was pretty
ruthless he's pretty freaking ruthless
so i think that one division would
probably be a lot darker
and more messed up with a mephisto but
what do you think man what you think
i would hope so i would hope so my
thinking if you're gonna redo
one division the true what if version of
that would be like
what if agatha was the one who
was trying to persevere through grief
and then
wanda messed with her you know so it was
like
yeah like what yeah what if i get that
became the scarlet witch that's yeah
exactly right
uh that or if like what if like vision
was the focal character if it was vision
wanda
you know and vision it's more of a
computerized version of his hex
so he's creating like a holographic
bubble uh and trying to
re-animate his lost wand it would be
like what if wanda died
in infinity war and vision had a chance
to try to bring her back
i would love that like he just builds
like a virtual world with
wanda and the kid oh my god that would
be so fun
that like just flip it on its head that
would be so cool
i mean as much as i gotta say as every
month goes by one division gets better
and better
like obviously there was some like
fan expectation management that they had
some weird choices on when it comes to
like
ralph boner etc etc uh i didn't need
doctor stranger mephisto to be in that
show
at all and the more i look back on it
and i know him to
you just rewatched all of it i love that
series
it just gets better and better it's like
we we truly did not deserve that show it
had no right being as good as it was
and like again with with all this grief
going on in the world with the with
obviously this terrible pandemic
it came at the perfect time and like it
and especially that line with grief
being loved persevering like everyone
needed to hear that and it's just
another example of how amazing art
is to to help soothe people anyway yeah
i mean as soon as loki ended
i um i thought loki was better than one
division
hands down like as loki gave us
everything we possibly could have wanted
and dreamed of you know
exactly and i still love it to me like
it's still like
i don't know probably top 10 marvel
titles but i wonder if like one division
has started to creep
up on it in terms of like my rank i
don't know my ranking is constantly
shifting i'll never do another mcu
ranking again
because i go back and look at that video
i'm like since then i'd move this around
and move that around
every day of the week i have a different
opinion of how they rank up but like
uh over time you know re-watching loki
it's there are certain
frustrating things about how it
completely changes the rules of the show
every episode and it does rob itself of
its stakes at the beginning of every
episode the fact that it does that the
fact that it completely
tears off the tablecloth and the flowers
are not still standing
like it's just a completely different
genre of show which i kind of love but
whereas
one division literally was a different
genre show episode episode with the new
sitcom style
you did start to feel like they were
closing off doors of possibility
and then arrived at some answers with
agave all along
and that twist of agatha all along at
the end of episode seven
as great as kang was i think i was more
tickled by it being ag
along with that song than just the
elevator doors opening and it being
jonathan major's
i loved both of the deals i just kind of
loved alec agatha along a bit more
oh yeah i mean like you'll never get a
reveal like agatha all along ever again
like you could only do that once like no
villain is going to have that baller of
a reveal banana
like come on yeah uh i'm so excited for
this series and i can't wait to talk
about it with umt
and of course to talk about with all of
you thank you all so much for watching
this with us
but that's it for this episode mtni will
be back next wednesday
with our what if episode one after show
and don't forget to
check out our many great merch options
at
follow me at eavos follow mt
mastertainment follow new rockstars
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcasts
thank you for watching see you next week
bye we love you guys bye
[Music]
so